a little a and then the ring around it
at what do you say anyways Allison can
you explain what internet is one word
netscape netscape they have zero concept
of what net say p pixel on is number one
in internet broadcasting the globe calm
it's a social network people will want
to log on I guarantee when we have a
price refresh your page seventy one
dollars a share it's the biggest IPO
sits Microsoft congratulations
it also makes us a target this is the
beginning of what they called the
browser's I'm gonna bring in a couple of
experts Netscape changed a game you were
Microsoft's University they were
deathbed competitors today we are
running a billion-dollar company dusk up
Microsoft bringing back their back
prepared to boldly go where no man has
gone before
valley of the boom Sunday January 13th
at 9:00 on National Geographic